et frédéric la peine capitale il faut
dire est encore la punition suprême pour
des centaines de personnes à travers le
monde il n'y a pas seulement la chine
exactement céline en fait les chiffres
les plus récents qui ont été compilées
par amnesty international date de 2010
est en fait en 2017 il y à 2591
personnes qui ont reçu une sentence à
l'issue d'un procès la fameuse peine
capitale dans une vingtaine de pays
il ya quand même une certaine tendance
on va dire depuis quelques années
maintenant c'est qu'il y en a de moins
en moins par rapport à 2016 il y avait 5
126 cas de moins mais ça cache un peu
une autre réalité un autre chiffre c'est
important ces langues de personnes qui
sont toujours actuellement dans le
couloir de la mort ces presque 22 mille
personnes donc qui attendent que leur
sentence se transforme en peine et donc
qu'il soit qu'il passe de vie à trépas
maintenant quand on regarde la carte
mondiale des pays qui continuent
vraiment d'avoir la peine de mort et
bien il y à 53 pays qui vont toujours
appliqué le fameux verdict de cette
peine de mort
par contre quand on compare avec l'ong
deux pays qui ont fait une abolition
totale pour tous les crimes
il ya la 106 donc ça veut dire c'est
deux fois plus donc il ya vraiment une
majorité de pays qui ont décidé vraiment
d'abolir la peine de mort certains l'ont
abolie de façon partielle
c'est le cas de sept pays et puis il y à
presque 30 pays maintenant qu'ils se
sont imposés eu même un moratoire
donc la peine de mort n'est pas
appliquée même si un procès décidé qu'il
en était ainsi
oui on imagine que la chine figure quand
même en bonne position dans ce triste
palmarès
oui exactement toujours si on se fie aux
chiffres de 2010 est il ya eu 993
exécution là encore c'est une diminution
depuis les trois quatre dernières années
vous parlez de la chine est
effectivement il faut savoir que dans ce
fameux palmarès de la mort amnesty
international n'a pas de chiffres pour
la chine donc mais on estime qu'il y
aurait plusieurs milliers de personnes
qui ont été exécutées en 2010 est donc
c'est impossible de savoir le nombre
précis
après la chine que vous avez l'iran qui
est une des championnes aussi toutes
catégories d exécution avec 507
personnes ensuite vous avez l'arabie
saoudite avec 146 le l'irak 125 et le
pakistan avec 60 et quand on additionne
ces quatre pays si bien sûr on ne tient
pas en compte la chine est bien on
arrive quand même à un pourcentage assez
élevé ses 84 % des exécutions dans le
monde qui sont pratiqués dans ces quatre
pays là maintenant quant au mode
d'exécution qui sont toujours
en pratique il y a le peloton
d'exécution c'est le cas notamment en
chine parfois on le fait même dans des
stades donc c'est en public même chose
également pour les pendaisons du côté de
l'iran va aussi le faire en public ou
encore même la décapitation est enfin
dans certains pays comme en tout cas
certains états américains
il y encore bien sûr l'injection létale
ou encore la fameuse chaise électrique
donc c'est la peine de mort par
électrocution donc ce sont toujours des
techniques qui sont utilisés aujourd'hui
en 2019 par les états unis donc ils se
retrouvent pas au huitième position
enfants et ça descend petit à petit très
bien merci je vous en prie